let's try and put it into context for us
how big an occasion this is
i think it's it's huge i think with it
being at wembley as well it's um
it's even more special i think something
we could have only dreamt of really i
think at the start of the tournament we
uh
we're here to try and win it and we've
got this far now and and
um i think we've just grown and grown
through throughout the tournament and
um not not put too much pressure on
ourselves
i think we've overcome some
tough tests over the past few years and
um learnt a lot of things and gained a
lot of experience from those games and
and i think all the learning curves and
experiences that we've been through has
got us to where we are
um on sunday so it's yeah massive
occasion
you know how england's world cup winning
squad of 1966 have
kind of been heralded ever since
absolute heroes of this nation
have you dared to think about how if you
win this thing
it might change your life yeah i've done
to think
um i think from my personal perspective
um it's it's approaching the game in
in how how we have every other game in
this tournament every other game that we
we go out as professionals or our club
level or
wherever it might be whatever
competition we're in um
and giving everything i think from the
outside and
what i've been hearing from people is um
the england team whoever plays or
whoever's come on the pitch or
contributed throughout this tournament
and the past few years has
is uh everyone's given everything for
that shirt and and everything for the
for the nation we all love the england
team
growing up as fans being able to play
for them now
we absolutely cherish it and
it's a special moment for us when we
when we do that and i think
as i said people are saying they love
watching us and
and seeing how we represent the country
and i think that's
something we should be proud of as
players and um
definitely on sunday we'll be out there
fighting for everything and
wanting to win that game more than more
than anything
what's gareth said to the squad nothing
different i think
he's got a unique quality of staying
calm in situations and
i think it passes through the team i
think the other day we were
it's the first time we've been to extra
time um
no one panicked or or got ahead of
ourselves and all stayed calm stay
stayed to the uh the game plan and
and it worked out well for us and i
think um
you know keeping a clear head and and
and going about a business as we
as we have done and i don't think we
have to change anything in the respect
of
um our preparation and the way we
we gear up to a game is is so
uh professional i think uh you know we
cover every aspect of
of a game and and what we can affect and
um
you know that's how we've treated this
game and obviously there's
there's a big prize at the end of it
that we we definitely want to
be on the receiving end of so um
yeah more of the same and i think that
calmness that he's trying to um
get across to everyone is coming through
it strikes me that you personally have
grown more resilient in your career um
better able to cope with those difficult
moments and
after those times where you've been
criticized personally or you've you've
maybe had to wait your turn to be
selected for club or country yeah i just
wonder whether you get to this stage on
the either such a big game and you feel
a vindication
for that you know that you've got
through it all and you where you are now
i think so i think um
all those times have made me made me who
i am now
um wish there was an easier route but
that's football
and i think that's in any walker life
you have setbacks and things like that
and
you know i've tried to learn from them
and stay positive stay true to myself
and
um i think on on sunday if selected i
think it's
a a massive moment
for me and um and my family especially
you know going through tough times and
things like that and you you see
all the hard work and all the dedication
all the after hours things that people
don't recognize
um come to the forefront of my mind and
make me realize why why i um
work so so hard to to to be where i am
right now and it's um
it's a proud moment as i say hopefully
get to be in the starting eleven and uh
experience what we've experienced
already
at um at wembley with with the fans and
and everything surrounding it it's been
a special occasion yeah
last one for me i'm going to ask you
about those fans i want you to speak
directly to them now there's going to be
50 000 plus inside wembley 22 million
plus watching on their tv sets and
elsewhere
at home what's your message to the
england supporters
uh um
i think it is difficult to put into
words to be honest um
i think we've we've we've definitely
thrived off
off the fans and and um
i suppose we're we're living we're
living there dreaming
and right at the front out on the pitch
and
and we can't thank him enough for all
the support and
and through the tough times and through
the good times and i think
um
yeah they turn up every every game no
matter where we are and
and uh you know the support is deeply
appreciated by
by os players and and um
we're proud to represent them represent
the country and and
um we
do them proud and do everyone proud on
sunday and yeah turn up and make a lot
of noise for us